console it's the browsers built-in
debugger you may have heard of it before
but try running console log console it
does a lot more than you may have
realized in some cases you only want to
console log something if a condition is
false in that case you're probably
looking for assert when the first
argument is false it logs the second
argument as an error
another trick you'll often see people do
is use console.log along with braces to
provide labels for the things that
they're logging that's cool in all but
change log to table and you get a much
prettier output as j/s developers we
often like to abuse console and that can
make things pretty messy use console
group to group things together with a
label then collapse them by default to
save space in the console things can
also get ugly if you're logging a bunch
of objects changelog Tudor and you get a
much cleaner triangle drop-down do you
ever find yourself manually incrementing
a number in your console logs if so you
might be able to save your sanity by
using console count it takes an optional
label and every time it's called it will
increment the count by one on a similar
note you can also keep track of the
amount of time between your console logs
calling time will start a timer then
time log will log the amount of time you
elapsed since that timer started now in
JavaScript we're often working in the
context of deeply nested functions and
objects when debugging it may be
necessary to traverse through the stack
trace of your code use console trace in
the function you would expect to be at
the top of the call stack and now we can
see exactly what happened before this
function was pushed on to the top of the
call stack and lastly every good Jas
developer should give their console logs
some flair use % C as the first
character in a string then pass in some
CSS styling as your second argument and
now the console is your canvas if you
want to see more short videos like this
make sure to hit the like button thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one
you